well the lebanese government has ordered
an investigation into the blast as we
just heard and how
2750 tons of the explosive chemical
ammonium nitrate
could be stored at this site now we can
see
just how powerful the blast was by
comparing before and after
photos of the site take a look at this
here we have a look at the harbor
before the blast we know the fire
brigade was finding a blaze in the
building that is circled in
red and now you see after
the blast not only has the building been
completely obliterated
so has the ground underneath it leaving
a water filled
crater and complete destruction around
that area ammonium nitrate is used to
make fertilizer
and bombs in 1995 it was used in the
oklahoma city bombing which at the time
was the deadliest act of domestic
terrorism in u.s history
what do we know tonight about the blast
in beirut
we'll talk about that i'm joined by
chemist and
broadcaster andrea seller mr stella it's
good to have you on the program
you've seen the video of the explosions
and what happened from them
we're going to show the videos again and
maybe if you could talk us through it
and tell us what you
see um when you're looking at the
explosions what can be surmised from
these blast clouds
if i can just say one thing i can't
actually see your screen
okay but i pretty well know what's going
on in the video so i will
attempt to um describe things so the
first thing is that there is a fire
burning
somewhere in the uh in the warehouse
itself
and that fire is clearly the thing which
which triggered
the really massive events that followed
there's then
uh a huge orange fireball which
which is which is produced and this is
the initial
rather slow in in kind of
technical terms explosion where
presumably the ammonium nitrate really
began to
burn and blow up but moments later
there is a second type of explosion
what's called the detonation
and this is one which really happens
kind of at supersonic speed and this
produces
this extraordinary shock wave and one
can see
that that that huge almost spherical
um sort of bulb of mist which travels
outwards from uh the the center of
of the blast and that's really a sign
of this enormous shock wave and that's
the thing that will really have caused
enormous amounts of damage can you
um surmise based on based on what we've
been able to see
um what would have triggered all of this
would it have been
just this fire because we understand
there were firefighters
on the scene would it have been
fires firecrackers for example fireworks
that were on fire that could have been
triggered everything else that followed
so you know ammonium nitrate has a very
sorry
long-term industrial history um you know
starting with ophau um at the at the
in germany the first place where
ammonium nitrate was manufactured
and then on through the decades again
and again and again
ammonium nitrate has has detonated and
has caused you know massive destruction
and almost invariably these things start
with a fire of some kind
right and and that's the thing that
triggers things now when you watch the
videos you do
hear some sort of crackling and banging
and you see
flashes and so it may be that somewhere
in the warehouse or adjacent to it
there was a consignment of fireworks or
some kinds of munitions
the fire department would call um
because of course there would have been
huge concerns the real worry is you know
what happened to those firemen and this
is very very reminiscent
of what happened in tianjin and fought
in in china in 2015
where again the fire brigade were called
to a fire in a port warehouse
and then you know the detonation
happened
we know as you as you just said people
know that this
chemical is dangerous and yet it was
stored right in the middle
of beirut we learned today for up to six
years i mean how should it
properly be stored
i mean you know that is that is really
disastrous i mean you know the quantity
is absolutely enormous
and you know we know that it has to be
stored pretty carefully
and especially not in the long term
because what it tends to do is it picks
up a bit of moisture
it cakes up it becomes much more solid
and and at that point it becomes
more dangerous the idea that you have
three thousand tons of this stuff
which is really close to residential
areas
just doesn't bear thinking about and
it's an indication
of an absolutely massive regulatory
failure
i mean you know we have very very
stringent in in all countries
regulations governing how you handle and
how you store
ammonium nitrate for this very reason
but it appears that that in in in beirut
there they got into a kind of tangle
between the legal authorities the safety
authorities the port authorities
that just led to gridlock and so it just
kind of sat there and there is a
complacency here
remember when nothing happens we start
to assume oh it'll be okay
mr cell before we run out of time do you
think that something like this could
happen
in another city somewhere on the planet
i mean this isn't just a beirut specific
tragedy is it well you know it's
it's incredibly hard to make predictions
especially about the future
but the history of ammonium nitrate
tells us that this thing
happens regularly again and again and it
really
underlines the reason why we must never
lower our guard when it comes to
chemical safety regulations
and industrial accidents happen a lot
they happen due to kind of
complicated chains it'll be very very
difficult to ascribe blame
to one or another individual there are
clearly responsibilities
all the way down the line and it will
happen again
unfortunately yeah and it's unfortunate
that the people in beirut
could not profit from the knowledge that
you know that i know that is
so common around the world what a
tragedy catastrophe absolutely
andreas heller joining us tonight from
switzerland mr seller we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight
thank you my pleasure